you wanted to see me captain my
husband's dog cheddar had relations with
a neighbor dog karate and produce these
two
smaller dogs he insisted that i find
them a good home with someone we trust
you can trust me dogs are my whole life
also work
doing work and hanging with dogs that's
my lifestyle
you're allergic to dogs aren't you nope
i just need an epipen because my
happiness is making my throat close
up hand me the small dog santiago
oh no dog allergies
grab the dog
[Music]
look at me do not
blow this for us you know what i knew
this wasn't going to work it never has
we should have just gone out for dinner
to a restaurant like we do every year
why did you make me invite them i made
you invite them because i like them
they're good people
santiago are you hiding in my bathroom
with a dog that you're deathly allergic
to
no
[Music]
occupied
it's true what they say now that i'm
fully blind forever my other senses are
heightened
i feel a door where captain holt's house
also the gps announced it when we pulled
up hey once we're inside maybe keep your
hands to yourself all right
captain can be very particular about his
stuff
amy this is a cashmere sweater
oh my stupid allergies we got into
kevin's closet
he was supposed to stay downstairs the
binder was very clear about that
why won't you respect the finder oh no
he's turning all the turtlenecks into
regular necks
charles you got to help us on it okay
the key with dogs is establishing the
alpha
cheddar drop it please drop it i'll give
you anything you want
oh cheddar is the alpha i didn't expect
that please please please
nice job boyle it worked but the mess
shake
the mess don't worry we're gonna clean
it up everything is totally under
control
charles's pants are on fire what boy out
the space heater get away from the space
heater i don't know where it is
i'm just gonna run at full speed
[Music]
where you are i got it
[Music]
okay it's okay everything's fine fire's
out
and this table fragile
i was gonna say fragile nailed it okay
security system
talk to me what have i missed what's
going on
aha halt used cheddar to steal the belt
but that's not cheddar holt and cheddar
always walk in a perfect lockstep
which means someone took cheddar and
that person has the belt
but who who took cheddar
where are you coming from why do you
care i thought you weren't heisting
i'm not i'm just interested in your
comings and goings because i care about
you as a friend okay friend
i went to the bathroom well you were
going a long time friend you feeling
okay friend no
it was number two and it was very
intense friend
bless you she sneezed dog allergies
which means that amy took shut up
traffic is shut down civilians are being
funneled into checkpoints good i just
wish my guys over here could be a little
more efficient
yeah i'm looking at you detective fuzzy
paws this is amy hates dogs amy or amy
extra stress
amy it's both amy's i'm under a lot of
pressure and also that dog is a piece of
trash
okay until something else is going on
you don't have to pretend to be mad at
the dog first of all i'm not pretending
that dog sucks also
my period's late i think i might be
pregnant oh damn i can't be pregnant
jake and i agreed to wait at least a
year until we tried i haven't found a
nope i'm not on any preschool waiting
list and i spent
all of yesterday in a room with
hitchcock in his new cologne which can't
be good for the baby it is
literally called zika okay relax
you're probably not pregnant it's
entirely possible hitchcock's cologne
disrupted your cycle
right yes that is a very real
possibility
santiago what's going on here is
everything okay yeah totes
right rosa uh totes why is everyone
being all weird today let's get back to
work and be normal
yes sir we'll do we'll be normal nothing
to stress about here
hey fuzzy paws i'm paying you to work
not lick your butthole yeah i'm gonna
get your pregnancy
test i'm trying to assemble my binders
but my new desk mate brian brought a dog
with him and my allergies are going
crazy
i'm so stuffy i can't even enjoy that
new binder smell he shouldn't have a pet
in the precinct
it's a service animal that he has for
made-up reasons
i have mild foot pain okay francie helps
me with that
how legally you're not allowed to ask me
that ugh
rosa do you need to listen to it that
loud yes
i'm trying to drown out the sound of
ellen the chat factory over there
my daughter got me a juicer for
christmas did you know that you could
juice
nuts what i'm two seconds away from
juicing owen i know it's tough but sarge
no shoe shoe can you at least put her on
a leash
she's a medical professional okay would
you keep a doctor on a leash
that dog does not help you with your
foot pain you just want an excuse to
bring her everywhere
your dog is a fraud come on draw a dog
frog dog
frog dog shotgun whoa
both of you outside now
hope your dog helps with neck pain she
doesn't help with any pain
i made it up i knew it protected boyle
i think you might be able to give these
dogs a good home
you are off the scooter if you have
fallen please call a doctor
i don't know captain i don't know if i
should okay
oh look at
tickles they like me so much
are you crying santiago i'm so allergic
can you tell the scooter to call an
amulet
you